bonjour et merci d'être avec nous sur rt
france alors quel regard portez vous sur
ces déclarations du ministre de la santé
c'est une note encourageante mais ce
qu'il n'ya pas toujours un risque que
les français baissent la garde
pardon paradoxalement il faut déjà
prendre ça comme ce que c'est que c'est
une bonne nouvelle ça veut dire que ce
qu'on a mis en place la depuis quelques
semaines dont fonctionne si bien sûr pas
du tout le signal qu'on peut à nouveau
faire ce qu'on veut mais ça permet
d'espérer que les hôpitaux arrête d'être
saturé dans quelques semaines ici quand
même si une très bonne nouvelle et les
français ont besoin de bonnes nouvelles
donc je pense qu'il faut garder ça comme
une bonne nouvelle avec ressemble donc
être en cours le pic de l'épidémie
pourrait avoir été atteint selon les
vives et rend à l'école vers sa
naissance elle pourrait donc être a
autorisé à rouvrir le 1er décembre avec
un protocole sanitaire en france
renforce est ce que ce serait une bonne
nouvelle selon vous bien sûr oui tout à
fait un
on est depuis le début a essayé de
laisser le pays et les travailleurs
continuent à faire leur boulot tout en
mettant en évitant de mettre en danger
les hôpitaux
c'est ce qui est prévu et j'espère que
ça pourra se faire dès début décembre
alors on n'en est pas encore là mais
selon vous comment devra s'organiser le
déconfinement et ce qu'il devrait être
encore plus serré qu'au printemps car le
risque de rebond est plus fort notamment
à cause de l'hiver on n'est pas tout à
fait sûr que l'hiver entraîne un risque
de rebond plus fort on si on prend comme
exemple les épidémies qui a eu au brésil
ou en guyane cet été on peut pas dire
que ce soit des pays froids et ça n'a
pas empêché d'épidémie d'être est
foudroyante
donc je pense qu'il faudra continuer à
bien surveiller les indicateurs on a des
premiers indicateurs favorables mais la
situation ce qui va se passer jusqu'au
1er décembre sera important les gens qui
sont dans les hôpitaux maintenant dans
les services de réanimation dans les
céramistes anbar ils vont pas sortir du
jour au lendemain donc il faudra
vraiment s'adapter à notre état de
saturation ouvert fin novembre début
décembre dans savoir ce qui résoudrait
et dans cette stratégie pourra contenir
la propagation de l'épidémie est ce que
les tests antigénique vous semble être
une nouvelle
bonne arme c'est vraiment très tôt pour
le dire ils ont été il s'en sortir
rapidement ils sont moins sensibles que
la pcr ils sont surtout intéressant pour
faire des dépistages à large échelle ou
chez des gens symptomatique dans les
tout premiers jours mais c'est vraiment
pas aussi bien que la paix sierre donc
je ne crois pas que ce soit vraiment
déterminant pour notre contrôle de
l'épidémie dans les mois qui viennent
dans l'impasse ce qu'on a actuellement
au total alors un mot si vous le voulez
bien de cette étude révélée par the
guardian les patients à faible risque
qui présentent des symptômes ducobu 19
sur une longue période présentera des
altérations des organes est ce qu on a
assez de recul aujourd'hui sur la
maladie et sur ses conséquences sur le
long terme
on manque un peu de recul mais avec le
recul qu'on a qui est d'un peu plus de
six mois par rapport à la première vague
il ya quand même des bonnes nouvelles
les deux bonne nouvelle c'est que les
gens dans les cordes qui les patients
qui sont suivis au long cours continuent
à s'améliorer même à distance ne faut
pas penser que si on est encore malade à
quatre mois on le sera à six mois on a
l'impression que chaque chaque semaine
il ya un petit pourcentage de patients
qui finit par récupérer son état de
santé est l'autre bonne nouvelle c'est
quand on regarde les examens qui ont été
faits en france par différentes équipes
il n'y a pas de gros dégâts sur les
organes dont on fait des scanners des
poumons des échographies du coeur des
épreuves respiratoires on a l'impression
que les patients devraient pouvoir
récupérer leur état de son décès quelque
peu laissé le corps d'un virus sur les
patients n'en sait pas grand chose parce
qu'on n'a pas un recul de plus de six
mois par rapport à la première vague
l'étude du guardian ils ont fait des
dessins vraiment très très faim chez des
patients dont la moyenne d'âge était de
45 ans ils ont trouvé un petit
pourcentage qui avait des anomalies sur
par exemple des échographies du coeur
des scanners procréa souligné ren on
sait qu'au nettement c'est pas trop ce
que ça veut dire il le critique assez
bien dans leur papier a d'ailleurs pour
dire on voit des anomalies mais est ce
que c'est vraiment des choses qui vont
gêner les patients plus tard ou encire
qu'un merci beaucoup d'avoir répondu à
notre invitation pierre tattevin chef du
service d'infectiologie au chu de rennes
président de la société de pathologie
infectieuse de langue française